fighter
[Music]
[Music]
fire
foreign
[Music]
all right let's go we just wrestled we
just wrestled now Brian I like I didn't
ask for it yep we're gonna post it we're
gonna post it on find the kid yeah oh go
ahead and put your trays in huh yeah but
you're hanging from this no big deal
dude it's early I do yeah I'll let you
hit a little bit a little something just
like on the front here you've had the
whole time that's okay that's okay right
is that true that's okay yeah that's
there's nothing more annoying when
somebody has that I tell them
immediately even if it's a girl I go you
gotta get you have something there yeah
guys are like that guy uh no it might
just be a piece of like dry skin or it's
piece of carpet
yeah it kind of [ __ ] up my new jacket
when you roll on me like that I don't
know why I guess there's a someone has a
dog in here because there's like dog
hair my jacket's ruined safe to say Jack
it's ruined safe to say if you get
anybody in the on the planet in behind
them
they're they're gonna they're gonna go
to sleep if you guys gonna be tough
enter Peter on prone yeah well you you
your shoulder you turn your head here
boarding might have something to say I
ain't Gordon might just snap my wrist in
two yeah oh cool that's a very different
thing Gordon Ryan what'd I say Ryan
Gordon you know who Ryan Gordon is I
know here's another one yeah he's a
different guy
oh you're oh dude that's oh dude you're
talking about Gordon Ryan
a black belt I'm so used to you making
those burbanks
you guys don't know him yeah oh dude I'm
so stupid you might be the worst at
names it might be the worst it means
yeah yeah
dude this weekend's us-280 Bruce Buffer
good luck you've seen the names oh it's
unfucking he has his work cut out for
him well now we got Peter Young
[Applause]
did I not tell you yeah I thought you
were full of [ __ ] it's so good um you
feel good right you're kind of like
you're alert yep you're not wired you're
alert you're just like wow yep
I do the Denzel face yeah dude you look
like
you look like I'm a guy about yeah I'm
about to get [ __ ] up yeah you
appetizer what you appetizer no I'm not
dude you are awesome blossom hey you
awesome I've known you 10 years now calm
down bro don't get crazy how many Magic
Minds did you take four
I only took one they're so good that
guy's so nice too yeah you know what
James Bashar James so let me tell you
about James but hold on before you say
so I met him
um I was at the pumpkin uh the Halloween
thing with my kiddos and I'm saying like
they want their faces painted like
zombies or whatever and then I was
taking pictures with fans about Nora and
then he came and I go yeah he's getting
here man because I was trying to get on
your skin and get a picture no oh no
dude oh oh no I go what he goes oh no
I'm friends with Brian and I was like
Talon yeah you know that's my guy man
and then he's like hey I'm the guy that
does uh a magic mine like oh dude
meanwhile you know he made he made all
his money he made it he made all the
money in tech oh yeah and then so he's
got his genius he's got 70 people
working for him he's 35 years old I love
him I love this guy let me tell you so
he's got he's got all the money but you
would never know it and uh yeah
the skin I was like dude you have a
Flawless skin yeah he's 35. I know but
yeah but I looked like well he probably
gets enough stuff like Morgan Freeman
but I got I got [ __ ] for you about him
so he he basically he was I think he was
the number two angel investor three
years in a row in the world yeah no he's
stupid got it like the original investor
in clubhouse all that stuff so I was
never gonna try it until I met I met him
and I was like well you look phenomenal
and then he was saying he used to drink
coffee like me because he's like you
drink a lot of coffee and I was like you
want me to go through my daily routine
he's like oh dude I was like my my
adrenal glands from playing sports my
entire life and having all that
endorphin release and all that stuff
they're shot and it happened really when
I started on Ultimate Fighter I just
couldn't get up for anything like
literally somebody'd have to bring
cocaine yeah to get me up they didn't
but you'd have to bring something like
that nothing would work and I was
telling that he's like yeah this is
going to help you he's like how many
cups and shots of special you're
drinking I told him he's like I'm
telling you because you're you know so
far along it might take a little longer
he's like just start with one next you
know you're only having one cup of
coffee he's like I'm not taking a quick
coffee which is that to me that went the
furthest because I'm like oh he's not
saying he's not he's not anti-coming no
and he's he's like I'm just saying you
won't need as much as so he had a heart
condition that's what he said and it
said he had 70 people working for him
he's got this huge company and he was
drinking you know like seven cups of
coffee and the doctor goes you can't
drink coffee anymore so he set about
with like real scientists coming up with
a way what is an alternative to Coffee
he's one of those guys he's one of those
Silicon Valley guys he's like oh yeah
you're not gonna let me drink coffee how
about I invent my own coffee but I'm
telling you I'm such a convert that's
what I was telling you I was like no but
you know I have to learn the hardware
I have to get my peepers on them myself
you got to get you I know I saw him like
well they're handsome six five Flawless
skin Flawless skin very nice big hands
big hands don't imagine what we're
working with down below right you wanna
sing about it he's Lebanese don't kid
yourself oh don't kid yourself oh that's
Lebanese he's a Phoenician yeah yeah so
that's popping right yeah popping yeah
so and then I was like yeah I gotta try
it man I'll go like send me your address
try it out to what you think today I got
it in the mail uh yesterday so I opened
it up this morning and at 5 30 my
stomach about five and at 5 30 I'm like
oh yeah I took my shot of espressos and
then I took that with it and daddy's
ready to take over the world it's a
clean it's a clean alertness that's what
I love about it you just you don't get
this crash you just feel you're just
like [ __ ] I'm I'm we'll see it's early
it's early Daddy might catch later I'm
noticing you're very you're very wide
eye and you're a little aggressive yeah
it looks like you I did math do
you're looking at me like I'm an
appetizer and I feel like it's the magic
mine yeah I'm glad you like it because
I'm I I was always like I was such a
believer in it and it used to trigger me
because I'm like and you know I was like
because I wasn't making I was like
Brian's buddy whatever yeah it goes well
I just like it because he doesn't need
the money I just like that he it's kind
of a belief thing this is a guy who goes
I go what do you want to do now you you
know you don't have to worry about money
and he goes I swear to God he goes I
want to get closer to God and usually
I'd be like all right but he goes to
India no he means like they should build
a ship and get close you know like when
we say that we don't have the money to
do it he's like I'm literally gonna
build a ship I'm gonna get I'm gonna
crack this you know elon's trying to
just get to Mars no no I'm past I'm
going I want to go to heaven I'm going
to happen I'm gonna talk to him come
back down to you guys that's that's how
ambitious and that's sponsored by Magic
no he actually just meditates he goes to
India and goes on these like Retreats
these ashrams and [ __ ] it's unbelievable
but anyways one of my favorite people
one of my favorite y'all he was such a
nice dude yeah and then meet him with
John we sent you a text because he was
like oh are you going to Brian's uh
celebration for his wedding that's his
his house and I was yeah that's what he
said he was at my house and we're
talking about that area right because I
used to live kind of over there and I
was like oh but it's on Sunday right and
he goes oh before you talk it's on
Sunday right and he goes wow because
every single one of Brian's closest
friends are comics and we all work right
so I I'm gonna ask you again it's on
Sunday right and he goes dude they did
on Saturday I'm like nobody can go I
said you know how you know what how this
celebration is gonna go here's why you
go it's gonna be Brian's best friends
and it'll be all Special Forces guys
that he just met six months ago that's
how this goes down and then he goes well
I'll do one on Sunday just for you and
the comics he goes behind that thing
I'll do whatever he wants his previous
Kim I was like talk to Brian he's the
best we gotta have dinner with him
he's really smart you know what I don't
like that's the second time I've told
you that story and you never go yeah
let's do it Sunday I know because you
don't want to no and you know what I get
it no I do I just and you know what I
get my lady is the one handling it all
the family and [ __ ] it's family it's all
family stuff
no I don't know what you're talking
about nah all right yeah I told him that
I'd go check his mind it's not gonna
happen his girl's running the whole lot
she's 33. you know what happens I don't
have the energy to argue
I used to have the energy that's why I
got you beat now at 55
she makes a if she makes a stand
Daddy's folding like a chair oh well
yeah Daddy lost his backbone now she's
usually right she's not drama there's no
drama with her that's what's cool about
her she's got she's she's usually if
she's going to make a stand I [ __ ] up
hey B let's take a little break but I'll
tell you he doesn't take a break yeah
you and I on the road
oh yeah I just know that uh next weekend
I'm in the at the Schomburg improv buddy
the Chicago improv in Schaumburg a
little bit that would be October 27 28
29th Charlotte North Carolina I got
comedies on November 10 11 12. Addison
Texas Addison Improv November 17 18 19
Naples Florida off the hook December one
two three and four I'm not stopping bro
don't stop can't stop won't stop where
are you gonna be um this week I'm in
Salt Lake City Brian I'm in Salt Lake
City this Thursday through Saturday
Saturday we'll have a fight campaign at
noon Mountain Time on thick boy YouTube
then next week Thursday Friday is
Calgary at the rooftop Calgary Canada
November heavy Texas San Antonio and
Houston Europe November 3rd through the
5th is San Antonio the 10th through the
12th is Houston and on all those tour
dates we will have some tiger thick for
you so on the new tour the Ohi thick
tour It Is by brought to you by Tiger
thick and it's at all the venues and
it's ready to go and we have batch two
the award-winning uh awards are on the
new bottles it is lit if you want to get
delivered to your crib go to
thickboy.com right now you'll see the
link and click on it shows up at your
doorstep get some of that award-winning
thick nectar right now do you know much
about Joy mode dude I'm glad you asked
yeah do you remember the last time
you're at the gas station you saw those
horribly branded erection pills oh yeah
I'm talking about it's like rhino3 yeah
you can trust those I'm sure there's a
lot of science that goes in there yeah
they're awful for you man you want a
20-hour erection go ahead no man that's
why I trust Joey mode and they're here
to save the day whether you're happy or
unhappy with the performance in the sack
why not perform it even better you don't
want a turbo charge your dick game Joy
mode sexual performance boosters like a
pre-workout but for bumping and grinding
it's a natural science-backed sexual
Wellness product for men okay it's like
a pre-workout for sex it's designed to
support
erection quality contains clinically
supported doses of l-citrulline arginine
yohimbe and vitamin C created in World
in with Best in Class scientists and
biochemistry phds and it is a sexual
performance booster yeah and joy mode
was created because those products on
the market especially some of the spills
are bad for you they have side effects
but listen man these guys take all that
guesswork out this is a better more
safer option for those things you get
the gas station all that stuff so if you
want to spice things up all right and
boost your sexual performance and do it
naturally without all the prescription
drugs we have an offer for your wieners
all right the final kid weiner audience
go to usejoymode.com fighter that's
usejoymode.com fighter enter fighter
checkout you get 20 off your first order
that's usejoymode.com for your first
order thanks Joy mode and thank you to
your wieners I need cyber protection I
need cyber security do everybody wants
my stuff yeah I need that all up in our
goodies I want I want a firewall dude
you well let me tell you something dude
protection it's a cyber world and we're
just some cyber girls living this world
and we gotta protect our identity Avast
is a global leader in cyber protection
fast yes for more than 30 years trust by
over 435 million users check this out
Brian prevents over 1.5 billion attacks
every month so wait empowers you you get
digital safety you get privacy no matter
who you are where you are or how you
connect yeah you don't have to be some
big CEO to make sure you're covered of
ass new all-in-one solution helps you
take control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features we
have free vpns award-win free AV free
firewall and so much more all right and
I love it because listen privacy
features keep your identity actions
hidden the anti-virish is great VPN they
don't know where you're doing it from
you you're at a coffee shop doing
business don't worry about about it no
one's gonna steal your stuff man so all
you got to do all right and we thank
Avast one for supporting us man it's
important finding the kid all right and
listen
when you support find the kid and you
support a fast all right confidently
take control of your online world and um
take control of your online world with a
vast one it helps you stay safe from
viruses phishing attacks ransomware
hacking attempts and other cyber crimes
okay learn more
hit him with that [ __ ] learn more about
Avast one at avast.com that's a v a s
t.com yeah you're basically Creek from
Game of Thrones right yes you're the
slave yeah yeah
and that's fine you've turned into reek
reek was about us and then get the dick
ripped off and then he's just like I'll
do whatever you want right that's a bad
impression take that impression back oh
my bad I'll do whatever you want so
eurek right I'm the Hound I'm getting
really grisly over time please when I
say I like to argue bro I could be
asleep oh dude with magic mine I
couldn't sleep last night and she's like
this and something I'm like oh it's go
time yeah wow I'm exhausted I still have
that in me sometimes you do I like I
wanted to get busy with her and then
she's on it drives me nuts she's on the
phone showing me how to work an Apple
calendar and then she goes oh yeah
she goes we have to erase all these
things and I'm and you know when
somebody's saying so you're listening to
music on like my son will Play Hard Rock
when he put and I it's too much and
sometimes it'll be just too much and too
loud and finally go hey what the [ __ ] is
this look at my head's been in that's
what's going on my head's [ __ ] I was
you know it's the same thing she's I'm
trying to I'm like sitting there and
she's we all have to erase this erase
this I'm like I [ __ ] go hey I grabbed
it I just grab it and I just throw it
away go yeah I don't want to do this
like I don't want to I don't give a [ __ ]
about my [ __ ] Apple that caused a
fight she should know though yeah let's
go she should know I know know who
you're married to yeah don't tell me
about your dreams not never also don't
tell me what you had for lunch right
don't care yeah and also your friends
and you you go to the zoo no pictures
unless the kids are in it right yeah
don't take pictures of animals that I
can Google yeah right there's no one's
killing the other or having sex don't
take pictures yeah yeah yeah that's
right right that's right also don't take
any pictures she doesn't do this but you
know people who take pictures out the
window of the plane triggering to me but
you know I try to have some perspective
as you know I'm like
and their family's never been but when
you touch down in La yeah if it's the
Grand Canyon maybe you want to take a
picture of the canyon Grand Canyon and I
do appreciate it when the pilot goes if
you look to your right you will see the
start of the Grand Canyon like I'm gonna
open the window for that yeah also
triggering I don't like people when they
fly especially it's early if they leave
their window open oh you don't no dude
I'm trying to sleep that sun is in my
eyes yeah so what I like to do is real
real Hound move I just reach over they
see my fat stupid thumb and go right in
front of their face yep you're an aisle
guy no no I'm a window guy you're a
window guy yeah so you can always win a
second now now um okay but if you are
I'll you'll you're not afraid to reach
over and just Kush no you mean a window
window you cannot you're by the windows
Oh I thought you were yeah
oh no no okay never if I'm the window
the person in front I shut my prison
French chilling oh especially if they
reach up you write you up and close oh
but you just see my fat stupid sweaty
handle
and then I go
and then you're looking at them like
they're appetizers if I'm on uh magic
man yeah that's no magic mind your eyes
are much wider than normal yeah I'm
ready to rock Daddy now the other thing
I'm excited about you know I hate toot
my own horn here you know I uh solved a
crime
uh I heard something about this now what
dude what'd you hear well you weren't
taught the NorCal serial killer I am
familiar with it and I know they caught
them but I I have no problem with you
saying that you solved it's going to
make me mad no I can't so I was going up
uh on tour the Ohi fake tour and we're
in San Jose and everyone's telling me
about the serial killers on the loose in
NorCal he was really doing most work in
Stockton
and that's the gentleman there okay okay
that's not what I thought it was gonna
be that's fine for a variety of reasons
right and it was going to be a white guy
in general well no not camel kids can
give them away right that'd be stupid
just a regular white yeah just in you
know normal Walmart it really is yep uh
was not expecting that but something did
give it away but the only official but
um so I uh wrote a bit on Saturday
performed on stage filmed it and we just
blasted out and they got him so I dude
you know me you know me yeah I don't
want to take all the credit no no but
are they giving me the key to the city
tomorrow no no that's the rumor I don't
think so did I just start that yeah yeah
I think but you could no I don't think
so no I don't think you had anything to
do with it but I appreciate that your
timing do you have a timing was on I
have a problem with them calling him a
serial killer do you know the definition
of circular is it more than four more
than three more than over a span of 30
days it has to be 30 days or more
otherwise just uh killing no yeah it's
more than three over it has to be past
30 days wait so so but if you people
kill people over 30 years like the
Zodiac Killer yes that's what I'm saying
that's past 30 days bro oh God I got it
yeah I seriously oh you know I'm you're
on a magic mine that's fine how come
it's serious murders often with no
apparent
yeah it's somebody who gets off on
killing
yeah but it has to be plus 30 days so
they were worried about him because he
shot I think and killed five people but
then they started to get so it was like
you took two weeks off three weeks off
but then it started to get like a week
off days off like we gotta find this guy
you know why they caught this dumb ass
because like the reason Ted Bundy
Jeffrey I'm not really but Ted Bundy a
lot of these killers go on like Ted
bunny went on a [ __ ] streak because
he would you couldn't calculate where he
was going to be right he started in
Seattle you know and then he was doing
down in Colorado then he's in Fresno
State uh Florida State this dude was in
the same kind of radius NorCal radius so
they're like they had an expert talking
about I was watching this morning you
know because I I was getting these calls
like dude we can't believe you helped us
out and I was like no problem it's part
of my job like it's not though but
you've gone over the top for us it's the
least I can do for your city so uh the
guy was saying though that um
he's so easy to catch me he goes it's
just a matter of time before they catch
him and this was an article two days ago
the amount of time because he's killing
the same area like he's not mixing it up
so it makes it easier for cops and he's
killing homeless people no uh-uh regular
people I think they're homeless no not
at all not in any facet he was driving
by and shooting people look that up and
this is my problem called the serial
killer no he's driving by but they they
they're not homeless no regular lady
regular guy I don't think so I thought
they were homeless not at all you'll see
the guy that I caught the serial killer
icon not killing homeless no hold on and
those those victims would be pissed he
was just shooting people in the morning
at night yeah but they were sleeping in
Parks Bob no yeah he was riding he's
riding his bike through a neighborhood
there's also his neighborhood a woman
was shot dude okay uh I don't want to be
like this but hey
okay I know the case let's see I shot it
3 20 A.M yeah doing the yeah on a
Saturday I think she was uh no she's not
dude it was just it he would kill people
walking by himself he they killed a dad
yeah they just yeah but look look at
this his wife Lopez that the pair were
made for 12 years was shocked by the
death he just randomly picking people
beat I know he thinks that they were out
though when he was late late at night no
no no no no no dude I solved the case he
was killed during early mornings when
people are out walking going to work
yeah and killed in the evenings uh-huh
they weren't homeless they were homeless
because I read that because when I would
read on the profiles of them they were
all they're not between homes not at all
not at all one was just a married couple
one was a working lady Jesus
so he would just see them on the street
hey uh here's what it says four of seven
victims were experiencing homelessness
that's the headline four or seven known
victims were experiencing homeless four
out of the seven yeah four and the
reason is because they were out you know
what the problem is so did you solve
this case because that was it no I did
but yeah but I don't know why you didn't
know that you know why I didn't know
that why because they can't give me all
the details but you said you know what
there is a clearance okay thing and I
was like okay I shouldn't do my job
well it says five of the seven victims
were Hispanic men and four of the
victims were experiencing homelessness
oh that's why I'm thinking they're
Hispanic okay
thank you homeless yeah well it makes
sense because they were he was people
who shot themselves in badly lit areas
yes yes yes yes yes yes you know what I
left that out yes
I did solve it I didn't know if that was
public yet okay is that what it was also
Brenda doesn't see homelessness
those are humans that got shot God damn
man they're your unhoused neighbor
that's your unhoused neighbor
let me try it was even a serial killer
at least more of a yeah but he's more
he's just got shoes people yeah but
that's he got off on killing people with
no motive he just would drive up and
shoot him so that's not my serial killer
oh yeah I would give that to him would
you yeah
yeah you're shooting people
tell what you think of this baby bring
up the profile because I'm talking about
if you're gonna be a serial killer dude
you know what I'm saying you got to do
it right yeah
it's the Dahmer one just play it yep
and yes that's my name and uh as uh so
there is a serial killer on the loose
he's in Stockton he's made his way down
to San Jose so you leave the theater
tonight head on a sweatball and Jeffrey
Dahmer's so hot right now right after
that Netflix song I was like ooh and I'm
in the serial killer or something oh
this is hot let me look into this what's
he doing her brain so was it was he put
a [ __ ] werewolf mask out what's he
doing as you research it this dude's
just driving my [ __ ] shooting people
it's not a serial killer that's a gang
banger with a good shot like this
you think you think you drive by and
shoot people and 10 years from now
you're gonna Netflix dot [ __ ]
you're gonna pull over eat their debts
do something dude it's a chicken takes
like a [ __ ] clown shoot a leave a
calling card do something dude I leave
here tonight I get shot
it's my day I'm the first one to kill me
I'm trying to spit off some ideas man
good right for serial killer yeah I like
it you can keep going with that oh yeah
but it's over now you know yeah they
caught them they'll be more thanks to my
help always seems to be more serial
killers always people there's like
there's like 60 active they get off on
the action bring up how many active
serial killers there are
you it'll surprise you I know there's
one in Canada popping right now in the
world or just the US uh just the us from
the world
man there's so many who just get off on
it how many series on loose today the
Denver prostitute killer they're between
25 and 50 active serial killers in the
in the United States is that 35. what if
it's big elsewhere like if you're
already experiencing poverty and danger
everywhere else like
do people think to become serial killers
in places that are already hard enough
yeah
yeah that guy they never caught that
[ __ ]
they never caught that [ __ ] man
I like y'all says first and foremost
it's important to be aware of your
surroundings
thank you okay thank you yeah yeah
thanks doctor no help give me uh give me
the uh UFC 280 I want to see the lineup
so I can say their names
oh not the main the famous guys we know
I'm not going to hear that all right
Bilal Mohammed Sean Brady Mahmoud
um
murdoth
the ciao
yep Vulcan
ostermere yep
isabaya
took hog off that can't be right Jesus
keep going zabara
Lucas Almeida
um
Abu Bakr
no mama get off is that is he related to
Gusty Omar God Jesus Jesus [ __ ]
Christ man
it's all Russian AJ Dobson Muhammad
they're all they're all like an Armenian
here they're all like uh yeah you know
Pakistan
Malcolm Gordon
Mina Landsberg but Bruce has his work
cut out for him right and he's great at
it so is Anna Annex really good at it
because you know they have a whole thing
of the fighters say their names it
records them how to pronounce their name
wow so they listen to it over and over
yeah that is not easy yeah that card is
tough
moradov I mean the the main card
especially the famous guys
my dear how are you feeling about that
card
uh well let's go through it first of all
do not skip Sean Brady believe Muhammad
that's uh Sean Brady's my guy he's your
guy monster monster Philly monster you
think it's a coincidence the Eagles are
undefeated Sean Brady's undefeated
I don't know there's something that
Philly water I watched that down Philly
cheesesteaks this Sunday
um Bilal moham is a beast um you think
Sean Brady's got him
I love Muhammad he was on food truck one
of my favorite ones but Sean Brady he's
my he's my Dark Horse now you know the
last guy said so I've I've only done
three dark horses in the career of doing
big round breakdown shop show uh below
the belt you ready for it it was Charles
Oliveira Arnold Allen Sean Brady
wow Charles Oliver when he was like yeah
you know two fight win streak well we
should jump right to it because I got
islamaka Chef I just oh hey who goes to
the main event okay okay okay God damn
it amateur Kevin Jacobian because she's
skipped that one uh yep so I'm going
with it that's cool definitely push on
Brandon the main card though uh dear use
uh gamra
dude that has potential to be fight of
the night
they're not doing our boy Darius any
favors he deserves a title shot camera
you're gonna walk through some [ __ ]
just fire because of what is striking or
is he he's good at everything but yeah
striking's ridiculous yeah Darius grabs
you
but dearish it's very rare I mean he's a
black man on the ground and you know
award-winning black belt but he fancy
himself a cockfight heavy on the car so
what's your where's your money
ah
get camera I don't like that they did
this to Darius and I love douche you
remember I was with Darius but first in
the UFC Corning Brian ortegan he's the
main event oh really yeah no serious for
a hot second wow Savage Savage loves
Jesus yeah yeah holy ghost power can
help you yeah yeah I wish I had that I
said why look at him look at him though
he's won one two three four five six
seven in a row at that weight class any
out of those seven wins one two three
four out of seven our performance or
fight of the night that's crazy give
this dude a title shot and this dude
doesn't have a boring fight no he hits
like a Mac [ __ ] truck dude and you
beat Tony Ferguson right and then they
give you [ __ ] camera it's
but it's like you're Changing of the
Guard you got these young [ __ ] sounds
uh what's his record oh that was Poland
polish yeah
his wrestling's good his striking's good
black belt and Jiu Jitsu Southpaw Savage
own his record 21-1 Brian go up to his
ADC stuff Jesus Christ right there keep
going nope keep going right there
so he won gold at the ADCC championships
he won bronze silver gold twice he won
golden 2019 214. the kids can be a
problem he just taught her experience he
just
it's just for dare you they're just
making walk to some [ __ ] fire they're
kind of giving them they don't think
he's an exciting Fighter
um no definitely not he's excited [ __ ]
yeah he's right besides like he's right
there with like Gage his fights are
[ __ ] yeah so what he gets hit and
it's game on maybe it's the I don't know
maybe the the Jesus thing the only thing
you Market it I don't know because he's
very like but it but it's him it's not a
gimmick he's very like where's he from
originally Armenian uh uh no is the
Iranian look it up
um he's very
um
Iran yeah there you go yeah
but but at 55 he's uh 150 that 150 he's
very similar to gaichi but I think his
thing is when he gets on the mic it's
he's very wholesome and very Leave it to
Beaver yeah you know yeah my but this is
I don't have an issue with it because
that's him it's not you know fake it's
that's him that's that's actually him
you know what I'm saying so yep I don't
know but he's walked through some
[ __ ] fire and he deserves it he gets
this one crazy win streak right there
kidding me dude at 55 that's crazy it's
not
all right go back to the card too all
right go back to the card what are you
eating boiled eggs again no no so call
it blood pressure medicine oh [ __ ] baby
let's take a little break from just
riling each other up dude this let's
just I'll tell you one thing I wish I
was wearing a Rhone shirt right now
because we are wrestling grappling now
my shirt's all wrinkly but if I had that
Rhone shirt on that scooter shirt let's
face it you got a dress shirt you need
to iron it it gets wrinkled immediately
you can't pack it this is a radical
reinvention you know my dad stepped up
to the challenge dad stole mine really
straight up Stone computer it's the
computer shirt and it's the most
comfortable breathable and flexible
shirt known to man and here's why okay
first of all it's got four-way stretch
fabric provides breathability and
flexibility it leaves you free to enjoy
what life throws at you you look good
and it's easy
biggest thing is wrinkle free you can
unpack it when you leave the office you
go to happy hour it's date night you're
going to movie a theater you're going to
comedy show with me in Utah Salt Lake
City this weekend you're gonna see Brian
next weekend in Chicago right sure you
could wear this shirt free Tech too yes
it's got gold Fusion anti-odor
technology leaves you smelling fresh
clean all day get your mind right
because dudes and ladies gonna ask you
where'd you get your shirt from and you
just tell them this you can get commuter
shirt all right you can get your
commuter shirt at rhone.com fighter use
the promo code fighter you save 20 off
your entire order that's 20 off your
entire order when you head to R hone.com
fire use codefighter it's time to find
your corner office comfort and it's
machine washable
you know when you're in the Flow State
yeah and you always ask me how do I get
in the Flow State and I'm like well I
don't know you've seen the movie
Limitless or anything like that that's
not really take that pill yeah but the
close thing you can get is some
nootropics from our friends that own it
have you ever heard of on it talking
about Alpha Brain yeah Daddy we're
talking about our sponsor for eight
years now at least you're talking about
you talking about the one supplement
that the creators and owners take
themselves Joe Rogan won't pipe down
about it he says help them form better
sense never done a podcast with him when
he didn't take uh we all use it man
here's the best thing about uh Alpha
Brain if you want to try it go and try
it it's you have no risk all right you
get your money back risk free if you
don't love it just tell them why and
they refund your money on the spot no
return necessary and here's what's even
better you can use this link and just it
shows up at your house and save 10 off
all audit supplements but especially
Alpha Brain or you should go to your
local Walmart but you don't want to do
that so go to audit.com
f-a-t-k that's on it.com f-a-t-k safe
temperature soft Alpha explain the
entire freaking site on it.com slash
f-a-t-k you're welcome
all right Peter John sugar shine wow I
still got the throat problem yeah
sure Sean is my boy so I gotta go sure
now now
um if you're betting
you know Peter Young would be the smart
money in terms of but if you're gonna
make money you take because you take
sugar because sugar is a lot for Peter
Young sugar is very confident
he's got that striking from that
distance I don't know because you know
pierreon walks towards you
yeah crowds you yeah and then does this
thing but he does no I know no but he
closes distance and then he's got you
but but I mean he's like he's striking
if it works ridiculous and and they're
gonna attach sugar Shawn's take down the
face which I think people will be
surprised by and then also the leg kicks
I'm not saying it's a hole for sugar but
it's a hole for sure as far as if you
don't go back and watch tape you watch
that Cheeto verified I know those light
kicks were an issue well Peter Young can
[ __ ] kick you could make the argument
too
that Petron in many ways is the best
striker in 35 35. I don't know if he's
the best Striker he I think he's the
best I think he's the best mixed martial
artist he's the toughest son of a [ __ ]
that's right yeah he's the best 35 some
monsters but yeah um I do think if what
favors sugar Sean obviously his height
reach stuff like that Peter John slow
starter but he's used to fighting five
rounds and he'll usually give the first
three minutes he'll give a first round
of weight just download the data yes he
does you can't you can't give a round
away when there's three that favor sugar
so hopefully's coming forward three
rounds favorite sugar too because cardio
wise and also Peter John's used to five
so I'm so curious on this is Peter on
you know he's gonna have to apply
pressure come when you apply pressure on
sugar that's he's a counter Striker now
he is I'll light you up he is but I
would here's what I would say out of you
tell me this B
if you have to who's the harder punt
who's the one the one knockout shot
power out of those two
I know I believe I would I think it's
actually Sean I disagree really Sean
Sean can hit you from that distance
um
I I don't know that Peter Yan has I
haven't seen him when he fought uh
Sterling I mean he was doing all kinds
of [ __ ] he has some power though yeah
I don't know who has I I 35 I think they
both weather that
I I think if you get clipped by Beyond
it's gonna be a problem sugar he's being
a counter Striker too yeah when you're
coming in I think it helps his power
right because you use the momentum but
if it if you're going toe for toe if
you're if one of those stupid you know
power bags was actually legit I think
Peter Young hit harder
maybe I just think that what Sean has to
worry about is what you said is
obviously those low kicks
that might take the fish team which they
are are watching film you watch that
Cheeto fight I know sugar you know he's
like I won that did whatever
cheetah one off I did Cheeto was
lighting his leg up and the fight was
stopped because of the light kicks
Peter Young can like you buddy yes
perian is yeah you can do all of it what
do you want to do what I think is
amazing is he's able to just stand right
in the pocket and and slip your shots
catch your shots in his hands the
question the question is is we like
obviously Sugar's not battle tested
right right you know the fight against
Pedro Munoz we didn't find out much yeah
Cheeto you know that was probably
stuff's fight he did lose yeah there's
nothing pretty Unbound testing
also please understand professional
boxer in in this native Russia trains in
Singapore are Russian stuff
Russia some would say the Russians the
toughest right well you know to become a
professional boxer in Russia it's gonna
you're gonna you're gonna learn some
technique yeah that that that that
fights just a big question mark it's I
think the UFC I don't think it's too too
much too soon for Peter or for sugar
Shawn I think UFC's like all right we
have taken our time with them it's [ __ ]
or get off the pot yeah and also if he
wins UFC needs a new start because
Conor's older right in doing his thing
Nate's out yeah uh your next biggest
star spray is he John's coming back we
need something I think he also remember
he's also the only guy on this card the
look at the card he's the only guy that
brings in a younger demo I agree the
twitch he's he's massive and also
there's there's more pressure on Peter
Yan Sean loses it you're losing to Peter
yacht as long as John doesn't get
starched right he had starch right then
all the critics the hairs go apologies
not very good yeah which isn't true yeah
but if he gets starts in the first round
How about if he gets his leg [ __ ] up
and it's gonna be a problem if if Sean
has no success against period yeah it's
gonna be a problem right now he's still
gonna be fine he's still gonna have a
career but Sean wins this it's
guaranteed title shot buddy that's what
this is that's crazy and also for the
division UFC is brilliant with this
match matchmaking because if Peter yon
wins and Al Jermain Sterling wins into a
third like we're like all right dude we
got it what do you do right so the best
is would be if in this who I hope wins
because TJ's my boy you have TFT I'm the
most excited about by the way
oh I'm excited about someone well I'm
I'm freaking I'm sorry we'll get to that
in a sec but uh Al Jermaine and TJ if TJ
were to win dude Sean O'Malley TJ's oh
my God fantastic fight now I think worst
match up for Suga as far as the top five
goes and this is insane to say but just
stylistically Peter John is the best
matchup which is nuts which means none
of them are good because
forward press forward he's not a
wrestler by trade no that's not his he's
got great hips hard to break down but
other than that yeah and now and he's
got those [ __ ] trips he's gonna do some
stuff but overall he's he's you know
someone's me tough I'm sure do you know
what Peter Yan is Russian
meaning he's violent and mean like he's
[ __ ] I get a sense of like almost
like if he wasn't a pro fighter he'd be
in jail somewhere he's a violent
[ __ ] he's just mean and violent
I get that from him I just get this
thing where he's just like
now you know who who should have been
born and raised by the wolves in Russia
but he's not and who's more of a demon
than him TJ Dillashaw true if you talk
about Kobe mentality
when you want to talk about people with
that you know when people go I'm willing
to die in there I would say on that card
there's maybe two I agree the Russian
Peter Young you know what there's so
many Russians that he's saying so
there's probably way more than two I'm
just saying uh I guarantee you Peter
Young and out of anybody TJ is willing
to do ready whatever takes to win
Saturday night bring up bring up his
Instagram for a second though take a
look at PJ's TJ's body calm PJ
he is I call it Guy Gordon he is such he
is such a [ __ ] um I couldn't agree
more like there's no one like him look
at look at this look at him there look
at him he's as close to a human Pitbull
as you get you don't get in better shape
you just don't get you don't get your
body in better than that in terms of
just his his conditioning and the kind
of training he does and also people
report from his training here like it's
not just him saying I have his mentality
people are always like oh he goes harder
than I know we had the same coach they
were talking about you've never seen
anything he won't take him down like he
even in practice apparently
I've been knowledging you never see
nothing like it I believe it you know
when he's the closest we have an MMA as
the Kobe Bryant mentality shows up
before everybody else sleeps on the mats
literally
guys different levels sociopath when it
comes to fighting sociopaths like
straight up [ __ ] Savage here's the
other thing and this is I was talking
about this on the shop show he got a
root for TJ he he's a a comeback story
when uh in America did we not favor a
comeback story a guy getting busted for
uh PDS right you Sada he got busted dude
well for uh EPO which do me a favor
listen uh EPO helps out so much take EPL
yeah it does very well it does very
little right so but anyway he got busted
doing that and then law not only do you
get busted but he got knocked down the
fight on a small weight class to Henny
sudo then he can't make any income for
two years
the guy trains his ass off he got the
pressure beat trains us off has kids has
a wife has a mortgage right he's trying
to get his life back together two years
off comes back they give him Corey
sander Higgin the Sandman who's ranked
number two or three in the world at the
time
after two years of nothing nothing fight
someone with one leg
beat him with one leg beat him one leg
and then now he's fighting for the title
this is a comeback story this is a
success story this is a rocky story I'm
rooting so hard for you I'm rooting so
hard this is why else you should root
for him because this is it yeah this is
the final chapter yeah if he loses never
comes again this is it yeah that's why
algebrae who I also love but I don't
know him like DJ but Al Jermaine he's
gonna be fine I'll change young he's
gonna get more title shots he does his
thing TJ's TJ's TJ this is x 36 this is
it dude this closed curtains Hood offend
the belt maybe a few times but this is
it dude he's never gonna get there again
that's the pressure on TJ that's why
he's in that [ __ ] shape
I mean he's just started he's such an
extreme and that's just the co-main
Brian that's the co-main event you're
yeah because your money now I gotta ask
you your money's on TJ all day every day
me too did you hear the uh Peter was the
one who asked for the fight with sugar
shot I didn't know that I heard that on
Ariel he was like I was the one who
asked for it because everyone else is
busy and like so it was interesting it
makes sense for Peter everyone's tied up
it's like the division's all weird yeah
he's like give me sugar yeah and then he
called chicken she was like we're
[ __ ] well because sugar always tweets
at him Sugar's been tweeting at him
forever yeah she was like hey she could
like I guess he always has a problem
when he talks [ __ ] like two years he
goes uh Peter come beat me up and
Peter's like you high again Sean all
right
um Main Event b Sean Sean O'Malley's
jokes around Sean O'Malley like pretends
you know he's he's a personality dresses
in a certain way don't get it twisted
though he's a [ __ ] fighter through
and through that [ __ ] he can
fight no joke give us the main event
breakdown B
give us the count breakdown for them
okay so here's the Charles Oliveira
Islam so here's the thing
I love Charles Oliveira for a thousand
reasons I love that he something
happened when his daughter was born he
decided he was going to be a champion I
don't know what happened I love that he
can't see without his glasses I love him
he was eight and eight right he was
eight he's been in UFC since he was 20.
it's unreal he comes from I think
nothing correct
um I love that he is a true champion who
does everything so well his striking is
so on point and so accurate okay you
[ __ ] up with him you're building him up
to 10 right keep going his that's what
you're doing I see what you're doing I
can see it from here it's so sneaky it's
crazy well don't say sneaky but also
he's also the most decorated one the
most submission bonuses of all time in
the UFC yeah keep going yeah keep going
makes it look you're like oh my God now
look at his resume look at his last
killers
um and and and I really do appreciate
that now we got one two three four five
uh eight nine ten eleven the only guy
who I think I mean Jose Aldo had 12 wins
that's 11 wins in a row that's
unbelievable that's such a crazy win
streak okay I know what you're doing
you're trying to play Blues hey you reek
no yeah you lost your dick right close
your dick and now you're trying to tell
him are you trying to make sure nobody
gets mad at you just don't know how to
bet against
the dagestani
who gets you on the ground
and just Reigns elbows and you're not
able to stand up against him I don't
know how you stand up against Islam
because I would probably say in many
ways he's khabib 2.0 not true and his
striking
very very good really cool let me ask
you this who's the best guy he's beat
well let's take up let's pull up his
right maybe when you say I'm just
playing Devil's Advocates when you say
Bobby green
uh Dan hooker
hold on go to Charles Oliver's resume
blue towbers thick kid now Dan hooker
did go five hard rounds of Dustin
Poirier
right I know he's falling off recently
but he's like monster oh yeah
but so compare that to Charles Oliver
one's foreign
no so I'm from it's it's just and maybe
he is that good a lot of type
there's been he's not proven yet well he
lost once in that entire that's a lot
that's a good run right there but I I go
back to who has he beat when we're
talking about tip of the spear yeah look
at Dustin poirier's resume look at
Justin Gucci's Islam has the weakest
strength of schedule
well you're supposed to fight RDA who
has the hardest schedule of all time UFC
right and that fell out so that's why I
thought Bobby green on short notice I
think what's gonna happen but all I'm
saying is I think a lot of people's
perspectives are skewed because the
coach who's won the best of all time
goes he's the best lightweight of all
time you're like Jesus Christ yeah
khabib yep he's the best of all time
Josh Thompson who I love and adore dude
I've never seen him lose around best
he's him
I I'm gonna quote Josh Thompson when he
came to my show in San Jose yeah you
know he you know he comes up to me it
shows whatever hey real quick
tell me why Mark Jeff Beats Charles
Oliveira he goes dude
and all you just beat him makes it look
easy he mops the floor with him he's
like you're out of your mind
unfortunately unfortunately I agree
because what happened why do you agree
though because that's all I'm asking
with people that tell me this because
Charles Oliveira's Jiu Jitsu is you're
gonna hate this
but I want you to look me in the eye
because you got you got you've still got
magic mind eyes
Charles Olivera's jiu jitsu is no good
here interesting I know and I know that
hurts your feelings
but what's going to happen is Mr
Oliveira I mean Mr makachev is going to
take him down and he will take him down
he will take him down now he's going to
take him down and he's going to hold him
there and just hold him and he's either
going to submit him oh absolutely not
crazy talk right you think he's going to
pound him and then
found him over the course of 25 minutes
25 minutes yeah and that's a really a
new thing and and you don't know and now
hold on no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
because you want to play both lanes I'm
letting you just ride with Mike to have
you [ __ ] tears no the thing is though
is you I Mike I my Chef's gonna get him
down multiple multiple times throughout
this life all good yeah you're talking
about hold on yeah yeah the most
decorated the most dangerous fighter
most finishes by submission yeah he's
beat everybody yeah the most dangerous
of all time yeah it doesn't work again
but you're in there for 25 minutes you
say it doesn't work my question for you
is how do you know are you saying Bobby
green or hooker is as dangerous as a
Charles Oliveira name one fighter that
he fought as dangerously not but give me
one guy who's as dangerous so so I would
say that the idea is if Charles Oliveira
can stand up continually and then
frustrate Market Chef's takedown game
okay big if
big [ __ ] if
because you think my job's gonna come in
take him down every time well I don't
know that anybody in practice I think
what Josh Thompson is looking at is
saying when you he gets you down in
practice and it doesn't matter who you
are you ain't get no more practice
you're talking about practice I don't
care about practice you're not talking
about fighting a champion Champions find
a way to win but what else does Champion
have what's the one caveat here what's
the one kind of Achilles he healed with
Mike what is experience he's got he
doesn't he doesn't fold under pressure
and what did machev say when he was his
first headlining event and he'd do all
that press and he's like I'm so sick of
doing this he doesn't like the attention
he hasn't shown his full potential
everyone goes you haven't seen anything
your insurance full potential he's not
used to all the attention yeah okay yeah
it doesn't mean the most tension you're
ever going to get I mean after if you
win you can get more but this can be the
biggest Spotlight you've ever had yeah
Charles will deliver a thrives the ride
and you're in there for 25 minutes I
mean it's the most dangerous human being
that we have on the planet 155 pounds
you've got documented yeah you've got
Jesus versus Allah on this and by the
way you went religious that's why we
both believe in one God that's all I'm
saying that's fine all right but I'm
saying that I'm saying that um I I think
the only thing that Charles Oliveira can
do here is to stand up
and continue to stand up so Market Jeff
says you don't think you can submit them
uh submit Market not not in a million
years interesting yeah you can't submit
the dagestanis not the not not at this
level I disagree not at this level
they're two they're too familiar with
the game a lot of guys The Familiar
traditional no no no no it's it's the
way they control your head and hips and
he's going to control your head and hips
and he's going to keep you pinned to the
ground no you [ __ ] up right because
this is where Charles Oliveira [ __ ]
thrives yeah in the transitions so when
mock Chef's coming in to get lock in
that takedown you'll worry about your
arm your neck
when he gets up you reshoot better worry
about that neck it's coming from angles
you haven't seen positions you haven't
seen you think you're safe you're
talking about oh Oliver you're shooting
in you're gonna pay a price oh and then
you got knees and elbows which is pretty
good at yeah it's pretty good no I wish
I was I wish you were on that and then
on the feet then on the feet
is dangerous has his hands full
Market oh this tip is over I can't stand
this cup is all the way full yeah he
can't stand it back he can't stand it
back but the polar bear likes to close
up close that distance throw those
elbows throw those knees but when you
throw a knee if it doesn't connect his
wheel you know who doesn't give a [ __ ]
about being taken down Charles Olivera
yeah here's the other thing about
Charles Oliveira which is kind of scary
this was scary yeah Charles Oliveira has
taken some shots thinking about Michael
Chandler that first round could be 10A
oh yeah Chandler was three seconds away
from fishing I think Sean Rivera Fights
Back beats him in the second Champion
Justin gaichi does Emporia but Champion
but here's the thing not only he's a
champion name another champion who takes
risk and fights that exciting style but
that's also why he's so dangerous I
agreed Macho's not dangerous agreed this
this is what could happen yeah if if
you're right and he's taking him down
wearing like a sweater you're getting a
boring 25 minutes probably and my check
doesn't give a [ __ ]
here's the problem if you said Charles
Oliveira works on standing up Charles
Oliveira is just you take him down he
stands right the [ __ ] up like a Peter
yawn or something I don't know he
doesn't do that he does for you now he
stays on his back and he's going to try
to get you with his Jiu Jitsu you're not
doing that with a guy like Islam
makachev because he's just in God much
of a nightmare in guard even in guard it
doesn't matter I don't think anything
matters to Market Jeff and that's I
don't think there's anything Charles
Oliver is throwing at marketship either
he hasn't seen it I just not sure I
disagree his especially in transition
especially in transition and again a lot
and I get it a lot of it but I'll law
this is what people have told you
well I've seen him and I know he's look
here's the thing who have you seen him
against a guy like chocolate I might be
clouded by the idea training party we
all are training partner for a long time
as could be and so when I see that and I
go your training progress could be now
your coach or your coach for a long time
as could be um
I watched khabib shut everyone down
so I go
and apparently he's tougher than khabib
hold on hold on hold on let me ask you
this
khabib in his Prime versus Charles
Oliver and his prime Charles levere is a
nightmare of a matchup for khabib named
the best jujitsu guy could be beat the
most dangerous bring up his resume and
this is the argument where khabib's not
the greatest 155 of all time I don't
believe that either when did you feel
like you became legit like like what
opponent did you watch where you're like
now I feel like The Vape is real or do
you feel like no never no early on he
was legit when he [ __ ] Ragdoll you
don't consider him the greatest 55 no
because he didn't do it long enough when
he Ragdoll to RDA no no when he Ragdoll
uh able to suggestions
I like went to gave him some some
business
um Edson Barboza look at that resume
though yeah none of them were except for
Ally quite a D1 wrestler but none of
them were Michael Johnson not a wrestler
not but no not first but but
B here's my thing with this yeah
looking at that level of guys name the
the most dangerous guy in the in how
Charles Oliver is dangerous and also
there's some guys on that list who are
black belts they're not Charles de
Lavera finishers and then on they're
either finishers on the ground and on
the feet there's nobody on that list is
both
yeah
nobody's both Charles Oliver and his
Prime versus khabib in his prime that's
a fight
if if Charles de Lavere wins this fight
hate to tell everybody out there he's
the best lightweight of all time hands
down love to hear a [ __ ] argument I'd
agree with that he's fought everybody
he's fought everybody and beat them hold
on not by decision yeah finish them
correct Monster again again and I love
khabib he's [ __ ] fantastic but you
can't be the best of all time that
resume
Charles Oliver's resumes light years
better yeah I have to say one
13. but a lot of those guys were not
wrestlers no they were Strikers and he
got you down tied your legs up and just
started pounding on you so
yeah that's a good point and when he did
meet oh I went out he couldn't take out
down I'll give him some business Connor
I know if people want to hate on this
she did the best out of anybody on that
list out of anybody on the list he
barely trained that's how [ __ ] good
Conor McGregor is did better notice
could be couldn't get couldn't he do his
usual triangle the legs couldn't wrap
get the wrist yep bounce straight yeah
he barely trained for that how do you
know
really what happened why success talking
too much crazy
wow Maniac he kind of said it about
himself afterwards and it was very
unorganized and probably was doing drugs
too but yeah you know just the you know
Mad Men but still with even with that
amazing
um did I sway you a tad or no do you
want him I'm very excited about here but
here's the thing yes here's it way back
here's the thing with all this yeah
you're probably right that there's a
reason why Vegas has those I hate being
there's a reason because Vegas is going
all right matchup takes so you know
Macho got knocked out early in his
career in the UFC he got knocked out yes
since then he takes zero risks right so
the money line on that makes sense
because all right this guy's gonna take
zero risks he's just gonna he's the
wrestler that's the money yeah I'm
banking on 25 minutes the most dangerous
man to ever enter that auction and his
confidence
and if this validates me the best of all
time oh it's hard to bet again if my I
mean it's it's one of those things like
if you said Mark sheffner gets knocked
out in the first round because he's a
little hesitant it's all you know and
everything else too smart to get knocked
down the first but um I I have to bet I
have to better yeah I'm sorry I know
it's not the bad what do you want about
I don't know we already have five grand
on uh
that's soon too yeah
two grand two grand
solid handshake dude you got a good hand
too buddy
buddy no I won't be I won't be very
clear now notice I'm being cool I'm not
asking for odds
you're taking the favorite here you
should win this bet what do you want to
do I'm saying the bet you know what it
should be if my chef wins you get 1K
aggressive right now so be careful
that's fine whatever you want to do
um let's be fair here because you are
taking the big favorite he should win
wins I get two grand but Charles Oliver
has to win via uh finish
okay I like that
yeah
oh no Mission no if he goes to decision
Charles Oliver is not winning I mean
because he's gonna take down too much
yeah and they're not going to give him
credit finding fights it's a boring
fight yeah if it's a decision that's not
the case that'll be so [ __ ] boring I
mean yeah
um that's what I can see happening
and he doesn't that's the other thing
about Market if he doesn't care if it's
born he just wants that belt
and I get very very get he gets very
interesting once he does get that belt
because like I said the Tide's turning
this young crap of Fighters are savages
and they're coming and they're not
belting they're learning the dagestani
system that belting you get rotated like
really gay dude threatens uh the belt I
mean there's a ton of guys coming up
that ladder yeah come on thumbs bleeding
guys I'm a vampire guys who uh you're
saying guys who who are wrestlers
you got your boy Bradley uh Bradley uh
well Bradley's at 70 right okay yeah so
but and it's not Bradley it's Brady and
now you're worse with names than I am
now that's the top 10 of what uh the top
10 155 rankings look at him just getting
ready for this moment yep
man it's so hard to be that good Jesus
cause Eve's a [ __ ] you got
um camera coming up uh uh uh
but he's also older you have some other
guys and coming up not even the top
they're coming dude the boys are coming
yeah the boys are coming yeah I think
now Islam has a style to you know be
defend his belt and you know but he
might be the most boring champion of all
time it could be that because if it's
just until he gets more comfortable and
starts breaking guys also and he he
admits this like he doesn't want to be
the next khabib he's not khabib yeah
remember khabib had a person khabib was
fun great personality khabib was fun and
also if you disrespected khabib it was
[ __ ] on he did not shy away from that
no he was on you remember when the whole
Connor and uh khabib thing and he went
at the press conference to apologize
like my dad's gonna kill me he's like I
totally just this is not what a man of
Faith does my dad's gonna kill me that's
amazing and I people are saying oh if
Charles Olivera beats makshev who's you
know the project of khabib that didn't
get khabib out of retirement like you
don't know to be trust me when he told
his father this was it and told his mom
he's not gonna fight he's a man of his
word he's so rich oh you don't know how
rich he is he said he said um remember
when I saw him and he was at 55 and
Connor was at 45 and he said if he wants
to come he wants to come he is welcome I
make it's welcome I was like all right
he's uh I mean he said so much cooler
stuff than that but yeah I just knew
right then I was like God doesn't speak
English but I like the way he was doing
it it was a humor but his English got
even better much Chef's English is rough
but so was khabib is my first time but
khabib's got really funny and you know a
lot of we're talking about Market check
because of this proximity to khabib no
even if no even if he wasn't we still
would if the guy's [ __ ] even if he
wasn't didn't grow up with khabib is
like a baby I'm just saying all of us
are going that might be khabib 2.0 and
it's it's to me that's unfair of it to
do that to Islam he's a completely
different animal yeah completely like
khabib different yeah they're different
can we uh and one says English got
better and a lot I gave a lot of credit
to DC because they would do those
interviews and they'll do those training
and they were hilarious they were it
brought his personality he was just
funny man
man I I want to believe in magic and I
want I want Charles Olivera to be the
champion you know me all I care about is
Magic I know if I came out here and give
you an Islam rant it's not funny no I
love it I love that you're taking
Oliveira I love it and I like a guy that
takes a chance I haven't seen
I actually haven't seen Jiu Jitsu solve
that dagestani problem have you used one
guy you're gonna see but have we ever
seen Jiu Jitsu solve the Dage but again
B you're going based off guys fighting
khabib yeah no but I'm talking about
well some of the other guys
name another one go uh who is uh well
well
um
cousin in uh the light heavily yeah no
no khabib's coming cousin uh who's yeah
he's he's in Bellator I think yeah 35er
I I he's a nightmare man he's a [ __ ]
nightmare
same idea you know I mean it's a beat
the beat wasn't really
a cousin yeah he came from that like I
just haven't seen anybody talk well zabi
was a striker I know he was but pure
Striker but I haven't seen anybody I
can't believe he's no longer fighting
Usman
you know they say abdulminop like he
didn't teach just
the ground and powered khabib style he
they were saying that he would he would
look at you as an individual fighter and
play to your strengths and like that was
his genius so this guy he's a [ __ ]
monster
because they're they're also doing
submit they the thing about it is
[ __ ] they have submissions think
about your examples he didn't even know
his name he said fighting beltor yeah
again this is all predicated off the
work of khabib and Dagestan so people go
there's no answer for a dagger stay in
wrestling yeah there is yeah just could
be so dominant and also look at his
resume but we're all like oh he's so
dominant talk to talk to my boy uh
what's his name we just have on uh food
truck from Penn State
what's his name what's my boy's name oh
nickel oh nickel
let me know how your dad is staying
resting chain wrestling does against bow
nickel that's kind of you're gonna have
your hands full
all the way full well unless you're
because
yeah but if you're clenched Up Against
the Cage that might be a different game
also just a different it's an MMA thing
okay well then it's an equal playing
field yeah
Bo nickel give you some fits all the
fish I have a question I have a question
okay I know it's good it's so dominant
we can't do anything against this like
well that's not true you're just basing
this predicate off of khabib's work yeah
he's the most dominant most famous guy
most recent well that's what I said I
said khabib the shadow of khabib is
alive and well so I'm I'm colored by by
his practice yeah
um if I have a question the hypothetical
if Henry cejudo makes a comeback
ready is he the 35 pound champion and 45
pound champion
uh uh I don't think he'd be looking off
you know volcanovski is getting the next
55 shot by the way yeah that's what Dana
said he's gonna get the next 55. so if
you got vocalosity for smart chip that's
fun
that's a good time but uh that's about
see and to me yeah I know I sound like a
mock Jeff hater I'm not in any facet no
Market jobs a better matchup for
volcanocity than Charles oliverus
Charles Oliveira for uh volkanovski be
tough
yeah tough much of better matchup for
him so I'm sorry our Oliveira ma uh
vulcanovsky tough because Volcan office
Striker reach and he hits so [ __ ]
hard and creative and on the ground it's
gonna be tough
yeah I think volcanovsky is is also
going to be stepping up to guys just as
big or bigger than he is
oh yeah so it's a weight class but
that's all he trains with big boys when
he came on food truck here I told him he
goes I don't trade anything under 170.
he's like 55 he was like everyone's like
too small but look at us he's not small
no he's not and he's like I'm also
stronger than anyone 45 in the world
yeah thick now 35 or so who don't
probably can do some work
he's been out a while though man he's
got his hands full with okanowski but
but the wrestling
yeah
wrestlers win man wrestlers are [ __ ]
you know if your kid wants to be an MMA
get him wrestling first oh yeah
get him wrestling the card's so good
though best card of the year I have to
do a fight campaign for it because I'm
on the road in Salt Lake City and we get
in the car I'm like [ __ ] man I wish you
could see this and we should be doing
[ __ ] pan and I'm like hold up it
starts at 11 A.M Pacific time during the
[ __ ] pretty early so we're flying the
team out Chin's flying it starts at 11
A.M Pacific yeah it's in the Abu Dhabi
so how's that been organizing that means
I get to see it though because I'm on
the road I'm in uh I'm in Chicago that
means I get to watch it yeah man so I'm
flying chin out I'm flying uh Casey out
we're flying all our equipment out we're
doing a fight campaigning for it with
Frank bear that's awesome and uh Jesse
on fire wow yeah
we found a studio out there the butter
Bros helped us buttery Bros
so what time will it will the fights be
over will you make your shows oh yeah as
long as three hours starts at 12 I'm
done by three
the main event the main event the main
card starts at 11 A.M Pacific wow so
let's say
every single fight goes to decision
you're still fine that's fine so it
starts at 12 my time let's say it's five
hours even five I'd be okay for a 7 30
show you know it said Magic Moment up
there did you guys know because you were
talking about I love magic before was
that a coincidence what they're
listening the page they do they listen
this is the Magic Moment oh there it is
yeah prelims start at 10 Eastern damn
now the early premium starting before
that
the earliest prelims are [ __ ] oh 10
Eastern yes that's what I'm saying seven
a.m here that's crazy which is fantastic
for me [ __ ]
the cart's so good I didn't want to miss
it I hate missing them
man that's a long road though Market
chef
TJ the last show this is such a stack
card oh it's fantastic it's such a stack
card Brenda do you get nervous watching
twice like big fights that you're yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah yeah I already has moved for
this one
let's do some current events oh can we
please can we can we can we can we can
we please can we can we can we oh what's
this is a pretty crazy bear attack in
Japan where a rock climber
I'll play the video first and explain it
but check it out
it's a black bear
oh is the bear coming back from oh he's
coming back he's punching him with his
hands that Beer's like Jesus Christ dude
but he keeps coming back
all right dude you're gonna keep yelling
it's just a replay
and see by himself I hear someone else
squealing no that's the bear making
noise oh
the beer was all Jesus Christ man that's
fine just wanted to eat your ass first
that's a that's a weird place
it's a rock you're very high up that's a
weird place to get exactly I like that
it's a rock climbing place somewhere in
Japan in a mountain
but so you've been with me Mark will
drive past the mountain I'm like dude
I'm so down just pull over and [ __ ]
climb that thing right now and since I
was a kid I've had that urge damn you
have said that to me that was crazy yeah
that's pretty crazy so he admitted right
come on beer yeah but I mean it was
still coming out I'm trying to get away
or just kind of still trying to get at
him I was trying to eat them for sure he
keeps coming back too that's a that
looks like a yeah it's one of those
furry ones you know the ones that have
like The Sideburns the Asian beers with
The Sideburns yeah that's what he is
they have the like long sideburns yeah
okay I don't know that fair but I bring
it up it's a [ __ ] we showed it so
many times
it's a sun bear could be a sun bear
could be also known as red pandas that I
didn't see much on its uh no he had all
the hair on the side was it Asian bear
yeah don't play here on the side just
put Asian bear bear hair on the side God
damn it yeah cause it has excited I know
but if you just type in Asian Bear yeah
there there's the see him see him right
there right there right that's him right
there that's it right there hey she got
her black bear yep that's him she has
the the chops yeah he's got some chops
on them let's see go back and let me see
if I can see that that key on it so you
see it yeah
or he just hasn't had a haircut in hot
second yeah let's see come back to this
watch look really look for the V
you can you can see the extra fur though
yeah maybe you're right you might be
right God look at the most trending
thing they caught that serial killer and
that's me all right I can't believe I
had something to do with that
[Music]
you see it oh I keep going keep going
it's hard to see you can see the extra
fur though I saw it see it
you see it there
it is now we're good thanks we're good
good job dude yeah
he's also foaming out the mouth these
guys has rabies yeah he's got some dude
a bear with rabies Jesus somebody was
saying online that the bear was just
trying to play do you think that's a
possibility no no no no no it turns out
the barrel was with the cub and the guy
walked into their territory yeah yeah
you know so he's like it's his fault you
walk up to that yeah you don't want you
don't want to deal with that delete that
stocking please Captain dude whoa and
here's another bear attack but this was
a grizzly bear and uh they're out of
space do you think it's too [ __ ]
grizzly bear attacks two while I'm in
college wrestlers and the wrestlers
pinned them
check fall it's pretty bad you can see
him here they went for a single leg
[ __ ] up one guy had a broken arm and
one guy just had had his face bitten you
can see his head to all the stitches
holy [ __ ] so that means his his head
small head probably what it is small
head went into the bear's mouth but the
wrestlers so you know how tough that kid
is on the right a bit I would imagine
would have done to that bear rough kid
rough kid beers don't [ __ ] Bears
don't give a [ __ ] about that bears don't
[ __ ] with bonus
dude bow nickel versus bear too come on
yeah there's four friends but these two
went on their own not fun hope there's
four room the bear attack two of them
yeah because they separated where's the
other two the other two wants to go back
to Camp or something like that oh okay
something like that they're all in a
hunting the bear be right back you guys
got this oh no but this this is cool
because one of the guys that initially
got attacked his friend came to save him
but then the bear went after the other
guy dude that's like remember the
mountain lion up in uh Oregon remember
the dude but that guy left well remember
he was attacking his friend he's like I
mean you to help good luck he runs off
the uh the mountain I was like where the
[ __ ] are you going yeah chase him down
ate him alive killed him killed him the
other guy got away he's like thanks for
being the guy wow and then they went to
go find the mountain lion and they found
he carried them all the way up they just
found the skull no just like drenched
seriously yeah yeah whoa
oh well these guys are fine now I'll be
I swear we've been over on the show no I
swear no no okay now was it drenched in
blood I don't know but how good was that
for a detail I pictured it right
drenched in blood well they did find the
the head now I don't know
then I was like like man that's bad I
saw you hesitate because you went like
that you went you went I went how can
this get more exciting for Brian
I do that all the time all right well
that's good that's an exciting story you
got scars in your face people go home
they did that move grizzly bear were
they covered up and the bear eventually
left them alone well he tried eating the
other guy definitely want to do that no
yeah
I think you just gotta fight man I think
you gotta [ __ ] not a crazy not a
Christmas Black Bear Yes uh Grizzly now
who knows yeah have you seen the speed
yeah this this just made me almost I
knew and I knew this would make your
[ __ ] ass cry because you read right
because you read just reek yeah your
girl
no dude come on put your ring up no this
is it I knew you'd see that when I saw
him like we got we're gonna show this we
covered on shop show but you've seen him
talking about this because it's these
are facts what he's talking about is
facts he goes I don't care what your
record is how many times you fought if
you got in there you're such a badass
dude I agree and people don't realize
like that the health that you're risking
to get in there and the gentleman that
he mentions he goes any of us could end
up like homeboy you know about him yeah
Cuban Superstar undefeated loses one
fight and I mean he's a vegetable now
just got hit by who knows and and
everyone he knocked out the guy he just
fought he knocked him out and was like
he's like I don't feel good about you
guys are like oh what a sick knockout
he's like I'm sure it's a sick knockout
the guy's okay yeah but he's like but
you're not thinking how this can affect
him a week from now a month from now
five years from now this boy shows you
what a great person he is you know I've
worked with him a ton you lost oh my God
he such a [ __ ] good person like a
monster of a dad like such a good person
he has so much passion I think it almost
his passion has got to know where he's
at but his passion I think sometimes is
one of the reasons he does end up losing
a few times he's he just oozes passion
he care he just has so much like his
heart's too big if that makes sense
beautiful he gets two emotions he's a
beautiful human being man oh my God it
truly is
I think you can get Joshua or Ruiz next
and then there's even talk and I talked
to French's uh agent uh Markell who's my
boy there's some smoke about him and
Francis oh
those guys both hit pretty hard for I
told his agent I said listen I like that
he'll be Underdog no matter what
whatever whether it's Jon Jones
Tyson Fury or uh Deontay Wilder he's an
underdog in all three of those but the
one he has the best chance of doing
anything is against Deontay Wilder yeah
just because Deontay will play the game
yep
badass when we can see Jon Jones come
back December 10th December 10th yep
against eBay
December 10th against steepe
Lebanon good authority
okay just waiting for some things to
happen
what is this
so BTS we talked about this before that
every Korean male has to go to a
military service so BTS they kind of put
it off on in 2020 but now they have to
go they look like a human I'm sorry
that's cool they look like women they
bring in so much money to Korea
oh wow so they're gonna be gone for
maybe like two and a half years so Korea
itself will lose billions of dollars
because of that and they don't let
anybody get an exemption like hold on go
back up to the picture for me you're
telling me you want to get on the far
left bottom row with a AK [ __ ] 47 in his
arms you want that you want that paint
the purple hair well
he's my favorite okay Koreans Macho as
[ __ ] every one of those guys has had
plastic surgery by the way are they oh
yeah 100 oh no yeah if you if I've been
a fan for a hot second they've they've
changed like the Kardashians over there
oh yeah yeah have your parents what do
your parents think of that the old old
guard
I'm sure my dad's more like you know my
my mom thinks they're adorable so yeah I
think your Dad throws up in his mouth
they're awesome but by the way they're
they're gonna they're gonna um beat
BTS look at this number the numbers here
it's incredible point one trillion
that's not good net worth of 50 million
so all them together the group yeah all
done together worth 50 million yet they
bring billions and billions and billions
of dollars to Korea yeah
these guys are um they just you can't
have those guys in a Korean military no
you don't want them in your Foxhole just
doesn't matter no you don't want them
unless you swing that way then you want
them
here's the thing yeah yeah here's the
thing do we if how does one of them the
guy with the pink hair how does that
raise angle real quick you want us
Marching for you you want us to defend
this country yeah have you ever seen my
dance moves I mean are they gay it's not
like Grandma we don't know no not all of
them look at the hair on the [ __ ] one
up there hey hey guys better hair that's
terrible hair man which one though all
of that they're all you know what I'm
sorry watch your tone dude they're my
favorite band no I understand that
they're my favorite band okay but first
of all the guy on top left with a green
hair lit also sponsored by Gucci right
endorsed Gucci lit I know but the guy in
the top left stupid talented I haven't
go off on his own when she started to so
they were gonna break you're a real fan
Super Fan then we're gonna break up
there's such an outrage they're like
[ __ ] with you they're like PayPal
they're like just [ __ ] but can they
get different hair
they're gonna have to shave that head
you would prefer shorter Cuts or what
well unless look I mean I'll tell you
who's very feminine I'll tell you who's
royally [ __ ] those guys are feminine
[ __ ] yeah they're my favorite the
favorite band but it's all five
transgender men listen I mean the guy on
the bottom right
you're telling me you want him
Defending Your Country well this is what
I'm saying I mean I'm sure they're very
disciplined but they're also
I wouldn't do I guess it wouldn't
surprise me they're so feminine dude
they're the guy on the bottom right you
can't do five push-ups he's gonna cry
I mean yeah how old are they plastic
surgery why are you so [ __ ] quiet it
was just funny hearing all this stuff
but the military that's more for just to
toughen them out getting discipline not
to serve they're not going to be the
ones serving they just have to do
service
if their freedom depends on these guys I
mean and that's the dance battle what's
that gonna be like for the sergeant and
their superiors they're gonna they're
gonna be treated like royalty they'd be
fine 100 yeah oh wow they're actually
older than their thoughts 26 to 29 okay
or 25 20. we got to get to the military
let's go guys
let's go uh one more for me and then
we'll go to Mark's stuff so Jeffrey
Dahmer stuff is being sold online like
his t-shirts and all this other stuff
and it's on Etsy and look how crazy
these things are these jokes
Chef Boyard Jeff Boyardee now with more
meat flavor choke me like Bundy and eat
me like Dahmer wow wow
your family exactly suffering exactly
would you get these though
no if you can't beat them eat them I
don't like making this guy a folk hero I
think it's disgusting the problem is is
the actor was so [ __ ] good and so
handsome you felt sorry for Dahmer
because you had some disabilities or
whatever
that's not real the guy who was [ __ ]
selling merch did I buy the merch maybe
okay
did I sign the petition did I signed the
petition to get a statue up in Milwaukee
Yeah
you mentioned Milwaukee
snake in his garage and it's just a
funny little he has a snake in his
garage
it's not a metaphor oh he's coming for
him oh that's no punk snake either no
that snake's not hearing it from you
yeah
oh my God is it nice
okay
it'll come into the bag and then nope
didn't work they're [ __ ] faster he's
trying to get away yeah so just leave
them out he's so dumb leave him out the
door what are you doing oh [ __ ]
oh this is sick oh swing your daddy look
he's going back oh my God what it's fake
there's a string attached there's a
string attached where's the string bro
the strings attached to a shirt I think
oh no it's not I don't never mind it's
not fake no you're right
did C pick it up and then you just slam
it on the ground
there he goes that was dangerous but
also just throw it outside don't these
girls like don't swing it towards me but
it looks way too calm yeah that part
looks a little too calm oh no I think
this is gay
I oh wow I think the the uh hey hey hey
hold on it'd be cool man but I was go
with the effective way you got a
criminal Vibe bro
let's solve crimes yeah yeah you got
crazy eyes
give us a few here's the best ones let's
do the first one there
this uh holy [ __ ] no guy gives it it's
it's fake but oh just your thoughts on
this and even introducing the idea of a
tattoo can look cool to your kid and
kind of putting it up my kids they wear
like they have like these all came out
oh that's sick um that's pretty cool my
kid you know because their dad has
tattoos and then I grew up with my
grandpa and Grandpa truck drives full
sleeve tattoo so I always want tattoos
yeah but my she looks sweet that's a
little intense I get it though but my
kids have put them on like you know I
almost like Daddy and they'll go to
school no one says anything but that's
like Pokemon tattoo that one's sick yeah
but I also like wear off you know I
might maybe I'll get some tattoos some
things
yeah see what's what uh let's do the
James Corden one
I saw this one this one's interesting
yeah
well I guess he was just a dick for a
while and then he what I like about the
story is that when he apologized the
owner of balthazarus all good come back
in you apologized I'm gonna [ __ ] up too
and we don't have enough of that in this
Society you can't people make mistakes
apologize your way out of anything right
yeah I mean James Corden sounds like a
[ __ ] there but he does sound like a real
big [ __ ] there yes he did but uh yeah
well the one thing I like you is like if
you don't give us free drinks and put
all the other drinks on the house I
would hate to leave a bad Yelp review
yeah I was like what [ __ ] go ahead and
leave it yeah lit up in the comments
well he I think he was saying I'll I'll
review you publicly and it'll be bad and
the guy was like cool let me go public
first before you do that you did not
sound good he did not sound like a good
guy in that but um people hate him huh
oh James Gordon you hate him I didn't
know that I hate him hate him yeah
he's not moving cats people like were
disgusted like you got like horrible
reviews just as his biggest thing by far
is not The Tonight Show in the city uh
it's a carpool karaoke yeah rockstar no
it's carpool don't say rock star it's
called carpool carpool carp with James
Corden yeah there's no Rock Apple Star
right there's no rockstar
they're in a car and then it was free
and then he went behind a paper I like
him I never thought and he's one of my
favorites yeah but he didn't bother me
wrestling okay maybe this is maybe it's
all fake I don't know but it doesn't
sound like he was very nice I'll tell
you that much you know but
it's weird to pull that card like I
would hate to use my fame to leave a
Yelp review I've never left a I've seen
we've stayed in some awful airbnbs I've
had some awful Service never once have I
got on there and left them a bad review
I I don't tell my wife it was this hotel
I wanted to do have you ever seen a
celebrity behave in a really terrible
way yes I have to yes I watched Sharon
Osbourne behave in a way where I went
I'm not gonna get into the details but I
won't say who it is but I'm a fan of
them it broke my heart and you know
where it was at and I know you don't
know who he is because he's uh
definitely a younger demo I'm a super
fan of his and uh it was at uh Justa and
we were there and he like was super mean
to lady who always helped us out there I
was like I know it is I was like this
[ __ ] are you kidding me dude
yeah and I told you I'm like this
[ __ ] guy I was with you he keeps
going I'm going to say something then
this lady she's so sweet and nice you
say you say what the [ __ ] am I saying
why is it I'm like oh hell no are you
serious dude yeah he might have been
hangry and maybe he was that I don't
know I get angry I don't act like yeah
but I watched Sharon Osborne I was like
oh treating somebody like way below her
who was a store I was like clerk I was
like oh I know exactly who you are I
know you're a [ __ ] and there's no
excuse for it I couldn't believe it I
watched her walk out I went got you on
that one okay her son's super sweet
though I see him all the time
he's a super nice guy super polite yeah
yeah actually I tutored him one time
like to prepare for this test I'm sorry
his daughter but also his son
all right
yeah give us two more let's do the
um
Meghan Markle was treated like a bimbo
it's the second from the bottom
so you know her podcast surpassed Rogan
only for a little bit yeah for a couple
seconds
um
total narcissist and I could give a [ __ ]
about her I mean I I don't know I think
this is out there before she was Prince
Harry who's like super soy boy now
before she was with him around L.A I was
in those circles
she liked the way the dick tastes listen
she was like she was she's a child I'm
sorry girl she acts like she was the hot
girl she's a black woman she's trying to
get with anyone with Fame so I guess
yeah that's my issue with this story
where she's complaining about being
objectified when she was on a deal or no
deal but it's like so I think she's
doing that for trying to be an actor and
you're saying anything it'd be like me
getting a role as a [ __ ] buff guy and
be like I mean Justified
you know all the models on the game show
like you know well they're not gonna you
hire ugly you know exactly but here's
the other thing she has a podcast now
yeah what else are you talking about
so yeah she's she's going I I liked
other jobs where I was you know uh
apparently apparently she owns Harry
that's about reek yeah I could give a
[ __ ] about her and I don't think anybody
else should not I I don't I don't get
why we give a [ __ ] what she talks about
Hollywood actress Prince that's what I
think your biggest thing your biggest
accomplishment in life is Honey dick and
Prince Harry and stealing away from his
family that's your gig you interview why
would I listen to your podcast what have
you ever done nothing the answer is
nothing but also well played well played
yeah well played well it's like Game of
Thrones very ambitious dated
strategically yeah smart yep God bless
you all good last one
missing Oklahoma men were found shot and
dismembered yes a dark one but uh that's
another case I'm gonna have to get on
yeah
so they found all these bikers like
in a river cut up and they thought it
was some big crime and then it turns out
like they were all about to pull a heist
like possibly on their way to go do that
so it was some like hero like let me
just kill them or maybe yeah or they
found out they were going to get robbed
or something and then they're like oh
you're gonna do that to me like word got
out oh [ __ ] they got murdered on the way
now they said bikers have you seen their
mugshots
maybe they were just headed there no
they don't look like the biking
community and I'm in that Community yeah
they're not like on the bottom left is
not biking he's got in the far right
yeah also the guy on the far right jelly
roll yeah right yeah yeah they don't
they got messed up with the wrong group
of people probably cartel guys
dismembered but they were actually
saying four bicyclists not even bikers
because that's you know so they're
literally owned by myself let's get our
make our getaway guys that'll pass it's
weird right
yeah well Brandon we did it again now
I'm off to London no no now the weekend
after that though I'm going to be at the
show Chicago Improv October 27th it's
next week yep yep and then Charlotte
North Carolina comedies on November 10
11 12. Addison Texas on my face Addison
Improv November 17 18 19 then of course
Naples Florida December one two three
and four all right
um tell the audience why you're
um
leaving
two
I'm going to London to uh our boys in a
movie
I'm in a movie oh nice that's not the
London thing but what's the London thing
just vacation no no I'm doing a
corporate gig
and why do I feel like you're lying
right now I'm not lying 100 that's fine
I don't care I don't care but don't lie
I'm not doing corporate who in London
was like hey will you fly from LA to
London to a corporate game yeah yeah
right I'll tell you making that up off
camera you told me it was a movie before
and now right after I get back to the
movie and which and you're missing
but then just a podcast on Monday
the Latin thing is
you'll see why I tell you it's not a big
deal but I have to go there me too yeah
show me something else
okay well I'm not in London I'm in Salt
Lake City this week Thursday Friday
Saturday Wise Guys Salt Lake City uh
Saturday at noon mountain time we will
be live Salt Lake City companion Bay
with Frank Mayer and Jesse on fire that
goes live on thick boy YouTube only come
watch the fights UFC 280 with us and
then next week Thursday Calgary Thursday
show at the rooftop we have five tickets
left so we added show on Friday that's
the rooftop Rooftop in Calgary Canada
the boys are coming up there a uh
Saturday will be a fight campaign for
the Jake Paul Anderson Silva we have a
great lineup for that November heavy
taxes San Antonio LOL November 3rd
through the 5th Houston the 10th through
the 12th then I end in Milwaukee and we
got some east coast states in December
but at every show and we got all lined
up the batch two of tiger thick that
sweet sweet thick nectar the
award-winning nectar batch two the
Ballers are have changed a little bit
we've added the hardware we've added the
awards on the side of the bottle and
it's gonna be got all the shows so come
have a drink with your boy at the shows
in Salt Lake Calgary definitely in
Houston definitely in San Antonio and if
you want to get some shipped to your
door go to thickboy.com you'll see the
tiger thick order on there uh to get it
done all right kids Salt Lake City
you're up love you guys this fine kid
we're out we're out